you mentioned Jason Whitlock uh-huh he
obviously another guy who has had a very
long career on TV he's also very
polarizing for a big time major you guys
did speak for yourself together yep um
which I believe that was your first that
you guys started that show together nah
Colin coward and Jason Whitlock started
it it was that's right it was Colin and
him yeah so you came in once Colin went
and and just focused in on the radios
right yes TV
um what was it like working with him
because he has a lot of very interesting
opinions yeah a lot of people say he's
kind of like Uncle Ruckus you know the
memes I've seen the memes man you know
like he's seen them too
um Wheelock is Whitlock one thing about
him you can say whatever
he is about what he believes and what he
says and that's what I like now that
doesn't mean he lives out all of that
I'm saying his opinion is going to be
unwavering unless challenged by
something greater right and I love that
I don't care how you get up to the top
of your mountain man there's so many
different paths
um I'm not here to judge in that respect
but be you that's what I love the most
about him now what's tough being with
Whitlock is he's always going to throw
some extra hot sauce on no matter what
he says it could be the most simple of
takes
he's gonna put some spice on it right
and at times I feel that's unnecessary
but that's how he serves it so you got
to either eat it or you're gonna be mad
at it you know and um
I remember when he first I worked with
him at ESPN 1000 times right and then we
he started coming over that crib he was
like yo your contract up you need to
come over here got this family style
show we're going to do kind of like The
Cosby Show for sports and you know
you're such a great father and what you
represent you're such a good dude and um
he was like I could let you have the
platform to do that right now I'm coming
off Sports Nation which was which was
great shout out Michelle Beadle shout
out Michelle Beadle Max Kellerman
Thompson there's a great show oh man
Carrie Champion LZ Granderson and that
was part of the point I could name too
many damn co-hosts right so here I go
again I'm going this way I'm going this
way I got so many teammates couldn't
build up like brand chemistry
um but I loved it all I loved the
experience and you know our show was
light-hearted personally it was great it
was a great show oh yeah yeah so we had
a ball but then he start talking to me
about this I was like it'd be probably
good right now to change it up so I'll
go over there and love my experience
over there to the fullest only two
things that really changed but maybe
three things that changed my whole
complexion of how that experience was
going was one the pandemic when the
pandemic hit you know everybody got
their feelings everybody starts
separating separating getting polarized
and even more than before more than
before right so I'm like damn yep I'm
just trying to take care of the kids
make sure they they ain't on the iPod
and iPads right 25 hours a day you know
way too much and um that was part one
part two was Whitlock left you know kind
of in the middle of night even though I
had heads up I knew people that knew his
situation a little Disturbed he didn't
tell me straight up because then you if
he convinced you to come over right
right so if if anything is percolating
right you're supposed to let give me the
heads up I agree Max Kellerman did that
with First Take day one he was like hey
dog what you think I'm thinking this
let's talk through it not like I got the
overall decision making no but it's it's
a courtesy right yeah and I didn't get
that with like I had to know it and then
just had to see him every day then
finally he dipped and I was like oh
that's that was real dude all good but
he left and that kind of left the
imprint on me like all right this thing
ain't like the team you think this is
which I kind of knew already but it got
hit in the face again and the last thing
was my agent left
um my agent was a super agent too still
my homie
um still the man Nick Khan who went to
WWE now he runs WWE and he basically
told me on the way out he was like look
he had a ton of clients he was like look
man every now then you got to swing for
the fences and he's like I've been
hitting a lot of base hits Doubles
Doubles inside the park home runs right
right right right like like he was
killing it no one thought he probably
from the outside should left but now
he's running WWE a billion dollar
company thank you that part so you know
he was just like you gotta swing for the
fences and that was a seed that was
planted that didn't Blossom until my
contract was up and I was like damn I'm
just feeling all that so long story
short working with Whitlock
it was great it was the challenge was
not us doing the show it was people here
him and didn't hear me so you know we do
a segment even though I'm challenging
them or supporting them they didn't hear
me they heard Whitlock because he got
the spicier of the takes yeah I'm I'm
not a debater I'm a discussor I'll talk
long I'll talk strong yeah he's gonna
say the crazy highlight the stuff that
gets clipped and puts on Twitter and
right and that was challenging because
that's not who I am I'm a bass like that
I'm listening to all perspectives to
grow A New Perspective and I just got a
little fatigued to that but I still was
going to roll with it because I really
cared about the show and I really like
what we were doing do you feel like at
times like would you ever run into any
uh
issues when he would take a position on
something oh yeah a ton and you're on
the show with them so do you get
associated with that or are they like yo
fam like what are you doing like yeah
because he was saying some of the
Kaepernick [__] I don't I don't know if
that timeline lines up with speak for
yourself but just some of the things he
was saying about cap and [__] where I
was just like yeah yeah you know it was
just like a little like off-putting I
guess to hear that on like you know I I
I again even like you know
we talk about him leaving and doing his
own thing but hearing that on like ESPN
or Fox at the time it's kind of crazy
some of the things he was saying yeah
and you know without particulars like
um Kaepernick was a hot button issue I
didn't mind that because you know I I
don't even know how you say this
properly but uh I had my issues with
Kaepernick as well but no I think I
think I think as the way you say it well
I think as it kind of the cap thing I
think as it wavered and I it felt like
he really had real opportunities I think
that that Atlanta thing that happened
where he had the workouts yeah and he
wanted to do the work out his way yeah I
was like bro they're giving you the yo I
mean I I I people have come up to me and
literally said can I talk to you for a
sec I I'm sorry I apologize I don't even
know these cats yeah I thought you were
sellout I thought you were against us
and all that and I was like dog I don't
even believe in all that stuff you're
talking about I just tell you what I see
from my perspective and my experiences
or any situation I knew Kaepernick
before all that uh I haven't talked to
him since but I saw the 180 fine you
know I see that ain't the first I guess
for me it was just like the demonization
of someone just kneeling to bring
attention to something obviously you get
into
three or four years later down the road
the lawsuit like he cashed out you know
what I'm saying and then he still had an
opportunity so that's that's the point
though this is the funny I I always tell
people I am not a hater right I just
tell the truth too early and I've said
it wait like day one I'm like I could
read this like it's like if you take me
to a workout and show me some defensive
ends right I need three reps I could
tell you who this and who down here that
fast so I read the situation accurately
um from that moment doesn't mean he's
not doing work but you said it best he
he brought attention but I don't think
the attention was going where everyone
thought it was going a lot of it was
coming back to be self-serving but he's
still doing the work I ain't even mad at
him but I was just like yo this ain't
gonna go like y'all think it's going the
way and the first play he could have had
was challenged the NFL not be
adversarial but challenge the NFL to do
exactly what he wanted but what did he
want he didn't know that's why he didn't
do any q and A's he didn't go out there
he didn't do a lot of things views into
any podcasts you mean a lot you mean
none none then also took that money and
didn't say any I mean he I mean we don't
know how much it was right no but I'm
sure the condition of him getting that
money was everything is
yeah if you're the NFL of course you're
going to make them sign the NDA of
course you're going to say you can't go
out there and damage our brand but hey
act like you want to play every single
year yeah and that's that's what you say
it's like if you really really really
wanted to still play I feel like that
that Atlanta thing the way he moved the
workout last minute I was just like
people act like this this at that point
I was like guys okay we gotta like and
you a couple years after me when I was
like guys yeah I know I was I was for
sure because it took me a while but when
that happened I was like ah this is this
ain't it what is going on oh you know
what's going on and it's just funny
because I know too many guys that would
die for a workout like I know dudes that
are beasts Ballers right give me a
workout dog that's rap it's on and this
guy had multiple chances and
opportunities and a workout and a
settlement and y'all trying to act like
they trying to keep him down maybe you
don't want to get up that's all I looked
at it and it wasn't that deep for me
right people act like he was the Lord
and Savior I'm like no government nobody
out here is saving you from your world
because if it works or it doesn't work
you still got to do the work so I'm like
why did everyone get so wrapped up in
that it was kind of crazy but to your
point Whitlock and I agreed like this
ain't it right but he agreed in a way
where people like damn dogs yeah kind of
caught up in a little right right right
right but I did my part too
um